I do not remember not seeing POI it was
just another thing that was in the house
it's oral history you're passing on your
history don't claim ownership of the
actual thing I just ask people have the
knowledge oh hi Mark hey friends so I'm
back with my friend Tash and uh Tasha's
been helping me learn some Maori short
boy style these past few weeks today
though we thought we would do something
a little different and I wanted to ask
Tash a bit about her experiences growing
up surrounded by POI next year from
drexfactor pulley sharing with you the
love of boy spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain today we're
going to be on the brain side of things
as we learn more about what it's like to
grow up around POI before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the link that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
becklinen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission hey friends so if you're just
joining us uh this is my friend Tash who
is bartender at the bar up the street
where I go to for regular Thursday night
trivia and uh because DC is just that
smallest city uh she is married from New
Zealand
and she's been teaching me some awesome
short POI style the past two weeks we've
also been talking a little bit about
what it was like to grow up in Maori
culture and being exposed to boy from an
early age so I wanted to have an
opportunity to talk to her about what
that was like so Tosh when when do you
first remember like seeing POI growing
up I I do not remember not seeing POI it
was just another thing that was in the
house interesting
um I would I grew up with my mom but I
would spend time I would bounce between
her house and her sister's house so it's
like my second mom and her kids were
basically my siblings even though
they're my first cousins
um and one of them uh Mariah she's 16
years older than me she had been doing
kapohaka which is what we call it
since school and actually when I was six
I also performed in a kapahaka group for
my school we were in a play and then we
actually I remember uh we performed as a
Kappa Haka Group after the play after we
took off our costumes and we had our
traditional bodice and the pew pew which
is the
skirt the grass skirt which nowadays
it's made from typically plastic and
like a black like nylon rope because it
is just to get the sort of sound and the
movement so I got to ask then do you
think that like having Poise being all
around is something that was like more
specific to your family or is that just
like a common matter experience growing
up probably there is the typical
experience in my hometown it is known as
the
so I'm from Rotorua it is known as the
cultural tourism capital of the country
so a big part of the industry in town is
tourism and and Performing like
Maori
arts for the tourists
um no yeah it's it's where if you're
from Rotorua you are very much connected
with maoridum in general and part of
that is
our dances and that is poi I imagine me
see I was so excited seeing POI being
performed outside of New Zealand uh the
first time I ever encountered it
Actually i s it was a
actually it was me watching something
and it was on the people of Hawaii this
was before I learned that we are
actually like literally just a couple
hundred years off the boat from them we
we were them so oh hey that makes sense
that they have POI
um
but the first time I saw it outside of
New Zealand itself myself being outside
was in Thailand with people doing flow
POI yeah yeah the Contemporary style yes
so I that blew my mind and of course I
had a turn please hold
oh hi Mark
[Music]
I did not see you there
I didn't hit her I did not
oh hi Mark
no one outside America's gonna get that
[Music]
oh hi Mark which brings up another
interesting question because it is my
impression that like traditional Maori
style doesn't involve fire at all no
no it doesn't well not When You're Sober
um
no no uh for what it was for us was a
way to maintain your Fitness
uh during times of Peace So the short
POI was for wrist uh dexterity and
Mobility for hand-eye coordination
and the long poi was more for
shoulder Mobility like your rotator cuff
your labrum to keep all of this active
and move in and they weren't the only
ones that we were using too but
POI there's a musicality to play and and
a way to perform that is just fantastic
for a big group so that's how I
experience POI growing up is is
yeah seeing woman now it wasn't so back
in the day
um seeing all of them perform the same
dances and it's it's mesmerizing when
you see it on mass well and that leads
to another question because as we were
talking about in some of the videos
where you were teaching me some of the
short Point style the POI in itself is
like a musical instrument in many ways
um it seems like it's a tool for dance
it's a tool for music so I get the
impression sometimes that a lot of poi
also has like storytelling elements to
it oh it does the the movements of the
POI you're yeah you're you're mimicking
a bird flying uh the the pattern of the
beat of the wings um depends on what
you're actually
singing about though like you're
and in hula you're moving your hands to
signify certain things uh for our
dancers we have something called the
witty where we shake our hand like this
and then we do large arm movements
um the POI itself is an extension of the
hand so it's just a little bit more of a
delicate way to do that I guess yeah
there's so many things to unpack from
that too like you know POI as a way to
maintain physical fitness as a musical
instrument
um as an accompaniment to a song like a
physical embodiment of some of the
lyrics it sounds like at that point it
seems like POI has a lot of Dimensions
to it yes it's part of the Storyteller
aspect too the songs which are what many
cultural songs are you're you're it's
oral history you're passing on your
history and why not perform the actions
to sort of really cement the information
that you're
putting in there yeah um so do you have
any kind of context for like in a
contemporary setting you mentioned how
uh Poise very frequently used in for
ceremonial purposes not just in a
traditional setting but also in like a
tourist setting as well
um do you have any kind of feel for how
that has changed how POI has been
perceived and performed within battery
culture over time no not within Maori
culture at all it is how we performed it
then is how we perform it now the the
purpose for performing it has changed
because we're no longer running around
China
yeah speak the English
but uh no now it's it's
just we do it for the sheer love of our
culture
um yeah you perform you do Kapa haka for
it and as I was saying earlier it's now
a part of our economy back home so we
love it so much and you you never work a
day in your life you do what you love
there's a whole bunch of people doing
POI back home so so going back to uh
when you mentioned seeing fire POI for
the first time in Thailand
um I have to ask like what was it how
did it feel like seeing this kind of
different
pun intended spin on something that like
has been a big part of your culture
growing up oh I was so excited yeah look
oh my God they're doing fine oh my God
it's on fire oh my God can I do that too
that was literally the train of thought
and then I ran in and yes they actually
let me do it with fire oh cool no it was
I was super excited to see it like
yay and then part of it was like do you
know where they came from do you know
who that is
yeah that's right and a lot of people
that do it these days do not know where
it comes from that honestly makes me
think of how you and I match because
like I I didn't know that that yeah
Maori when I first walked in that's
pretty much how our very first
conversation went when you found out
that I was from New Zealand and that I
was Maori right like so as soon as I had
placed your accent I was just like wait
a second have you ever heard of a thing
called poi
and like yeah
yeah I'm from New Zealand I'm Marty
and and there was a really interesting
moment there because you know I I
remember bringing in some sets of poi
that like I I had been set by other
companies and you better take a look at
them you're like what is this
so so the point you use for spinning is
much heavier than ours um no I don't
know what they used to stuff them with
pre-electricity
but nowadays it's just it's sort of like
foam and newspaper to sort of bulk it
out
um and wrapped in plastic and and wool
from like the craft store but um it's
much easier for the hits because you as
you've experienced you are doing a lot
of hits like that even with long poi
which
I I I'm going to when I say long poi I'm
going to be speaking specifically on the
Maori style of poi and when I say flow
POI that'll be your point you sound like
great Germans to me yeah so with long
poi you are doing physical like hits as
well and I would hate to see the bruises
after a day of doing some of those that
you would do with white boys
like uh oh there's a tick tock video for
me to make
I didn't know how particular I was with
the size that I wanted the the ball
itself to be somewhere very small some
were very big but they were weighted so
like getting used to that that move like
moving everything that that's more of a
workout than long poi is definitely it
can be and and goodness Only Knows uh
like people winding up with shoulder
problems doing that is Is disturbingly
frequent start with long poi save your
labor
so clearly there's a very active flow
POI Community around the world and many
of the people in it have absolutely no
idea that they are practicing an art
that started with an indigenous group as
somebody who grew up in it and that's a
part of your culture what are some
things that you would love to see out of
the slopeway community to show respect
for that so for the ones that don't know
and do pick up POI I would I would want
them to have the Curiosity to learn uh
to to look it up I'm not saying that you
know pre-face everything that you do
when it comes to POI with like this is
something from this place and it's
traditionally performed for these you
don't need to do that I just ask people
have the knowledge where it comes from
just just have a curiosity and obviously
POI is not an English word so like look
up the etymology of it at least
uh for the ones that do know what the
culture is just
don't claim ownership of the actual
thing claim ownership of the movements
if you've invented a movement all that
that's absolutely awesome but like don't
pretend that
you like you know all and everything
that that is pretty much it you're
basically just being respectful of the
history but
use the practice for yourself do what
you want with it like yeah but yeah know
the history I'm just asking people to
have knowledge that's it that I think
that makes a lot of sense yeah cool so
Tash thank you so much both for uh being
out in the cold with me talking about
and teaching me POI and also for
everything that you have shared with us
here oh that you are very welcome it was
fun yeah it's cold and fun if you got
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to keep the conversation going and to
help people find my channel and help it
grow
this video would not be possible where
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all if you're a very
generous support if you out there
watching are not currently supporter and
you'd like to become one you can do that
by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor Ploy and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out of my mission go check
that out please and thank you to check
out some of the other videos that I've
recorded with Tosh here I'm going to
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also uh you might like this top
video Here YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like it based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe check that out
as well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video very soon peace